以及agent在Lobardy上面應該怎麼去使用
這是一個核心的
然後我相信在操作的過程中
大家也掌握了這種基本的agent產品的一個交互的這樣的一個方式
然後第三是信息檢索
也就是怎麼樣快速的去生產出一份這個調研的報道
對吧
然後無論是你給自己的公司
給自己日常的業務
你所在的行業去做這種行業調研
這麼把它變成一份可視化非常強的HTML
然後以及連接你自己人背書去變成一份可以大家分享的這樣的一份文檔
那首先在這個小節是有跟大家講清楚的
然後第四是多模態的內容創作
這是我們最核心最重要的一塊
因為我們所有的AI生成的內容
無非都基本上離不開這幾個模態
大家日常工作裡面
文字模態 圖片模態 視頻模態
分別用的是甚麼工具
以及它應該怎麼去生成 怎麼去使用
我們在這個板塊對大家有一個比較詳細的講解
然後到了數據分析
我們怎麼快速的當我們擁有了一份
我們來說我們自己的一些數據表格
然後我們快速的通過WorkBuddy去調用專家團
如果你用的不是WorkBuddy你用Codex
怎麼通過數據清洗
然後再到後面的這種調點的分析
再到檢測再到護盤這樣的一個整體流程
已經變成一個可視化不讓強的HTML
這是在這個小節講的事情
那今天我們還會再聊一聊就是更深度的東西了
在基於昨天以上的
我們今天會聊一聊提示詞工程
以及SPEO的構建
以及一些企業自動化落地的一些內容
那昨天也有小夥伴提醒我
可以把這個二維碼貼出來
就是這是我自己的小紅書的二維碼
大家如果感情的話可以去去搜一下
然後大家搜這個名字也能說得到
因為我在裡面會分享很多
就是因為我們本身就是在從事營銷
跟寶寶行業
以及在AI裡面用的比較多
所以我們分享的大多數都是
曾聖者日常在工作中
會使用到的一些實操的技巧
我們不太會說就是一些渲染焦慮的東西
所以大家感興趣的話可以看一看
那進入真題
我們今天一大早
周日的一大早
就是要學一個甚麼東西呢
我們叫做在現在這個階段來說
大家每個人都有一個需求
就是把自己的日常工作去做自動化
以及說去讓自己的每一個
某一個業務流變成一個在自己電腦上
可以自動去跑步的一個事情
於是在AI行業裡面
其實就多了一個讓大家可能日常裡面
都會提到的關鍵詞
叫提示詞工程
以及在這兩年來說的話
就會就是今年上半年開始延展到現在
大家在小紅書也好社會上面
經常會提到的一個詞
Skill
也在我昨天的過程中
一直會講到的這個詞
那他們到底是甚麼意思
以及怎麼去寫
關於自己的一個提示詞
以及自己的一個Skill
我們在這個裡面會跟大家講清楚
首先提示詞這個東西
應該在座各位
沒有人沒聽過這個詞吧
對吧
大家應該每天都聽到Pront
Prompt
大家您用的是甚麼樣的提示詞
您用的是甚麼Pront
但是大家也沒有理解過
它其實也是有一個發展逆層的
就是提示詞發展到今天
它其實也經歷了幾個變化
首先另一個是我們所說的框架時期
我相信大家在這開始AI出來的時候
應該聽過一些框架
類似甚麼Costar框架
JSK框架
包括一些Price等等
等等這樣的框架
那那個時候為甚麼會出現這個東西呢
因為大家大多數的人
包括很多的老師也好
他們其實都是初次去接觸
這種大模型的內容
那面對這種AI
大家特別需要一種
特別懸不得這樣的一個
好像看起來非常提醒的
這樣的一個結構
去幫助你控制這個AI的輸出
於是就出來了
非常多的這樣的一個框架形態
但今天看來這樣的框架形態
它會一定是合適的
或者是說它是一個非常科學的用法
但在當時其實引起了一種很大的複潮
我們說那個時候的核心特徵
它就是追求這種固定的
可複製性的這種提示詞的模板
那到了第二個階段
我會把它調稱於基剛階階段
在這裡有人知道
李基剛這個人的嗎
有沒有聽過
不要對不對
李基剛老師是當時
當時其實有一點是這樣的
就是大家覺得AI的能力
怎麼去讓AI回答的你更好呢
無非就是一件事情
叫做用上更好的模型
這個好像聽起來是比較
比較順應這個認知的
但核心這個裡面又少去了一個點
就是在當時模型能力
沒到強的時候
有一些人能用的很好
有一些人沒有辦法用的那麼好
原因是甚麼
是他的提示詞能力
於是李基剛老師
作為當時的一個代表
就是他在提示詞方面
是非常厲害的
就是他等於說
大家都在用AI寫文案
他寫出來的
用AI寫出來的文案
就能夠去讓大家共起
那為甚麼他能夠讓
包括我昨天在講文案
他要趕快的時候
有講到那個共振法
大家記得嗎
寫那個
脫口袖腳本的
那個就是他寫出來的
他對這件事情的理解
非常地神奇
以及他有很多的案例
佐證他對於這件事情的理解
所以我們說
他把Pront去視為一種
與AI溝通的編程語言
然後去強調其中的邏輯
承測可識性
以及給出了非常多的案例
所以當時激發了大家
對於提示詞能夠更好的
引導AI去解決問題的
這樣的一個說法
這是第二個時期
那到了第三個時期
其實是去年的時候
去年隨著我們所說的
整個AI行業
慢慢地去往行業化
以及更垂直的領域
去深化的過程中
那越來越多不同的領域的專家
以及這種我們所說的
從業者去加入
提示詞就慢慢地變成
每個行業
好像都有自己
應該去做的
這樣的一個模式和規板
去年視頻模型
還沒有出來的時候
就是很好的視頻模型
那就是C-Dance 2.0
還沒有出來的時候
那大家在寫腳本式的提示詞
其實是需要非常長篇大論的
把每一個分鏡
人物腳本
甚麼都猜得很細
動作都猜得很細
那這個其實就是我們所說的
基於影視這個行業
去寫提示詞的時候的
一個背後的思考
那不單單有影視行業
還有圖片的行業
還有甚至其他
所有的這些行業
每個行業都有自己的一些
系統性
以及行業應用的深化
所以這其實是我們所說的
提示詞
雖然大家可能每天都在聽
但因為用的
可能沒有那個深的情況下
沒有辦法去理解到
它其實整個是有一個變化的軌跡的
從最開始的這種套模板
再到這種真正的去系統的
去結合這種
結合化的思維和工程思維
再到現在基於行業
不同的行業有不同的模板
不同的行業有不同的
比較好的提示方式
這樣的一個發展歷程
它有點像甚麼呢
也有點像語言的發展的歷程
所以我們說跟AI的溝通
又好像就是一種新的語言的誕生
就像我們的漢語
就像我們的其他的這種語言
編程語言等等
那我們昨天也講了這張圖
這張圖大家記不記得
就是我們說好提示詞
它到底是怎麼來的
它結果是寫出來的
它是跑出來的
第一件事情是
你要先想清楚一件問題
叫做你到底要解決
甚麼樣的任務
你今天要解決的可能是
你想要給自己的工作
去解決
類似說自動化的問題
你想要去給
你樓下保安寫一個小程序
我們有一些
有很有趣的朋友
他們會覺得樓下
那個保安的台班
台的不是很科學
然後去用提示詞
就給他們寫了一些
台班的小程序
你要先理解清楚
自己今天要解決的問題是甚麼
其中可能會涉及到一些要素
類似說目標對象
輸入輸出標準的邊界
這個是我們能解決一個問題的前提
那從想清楚的時候
第二步其實就是
跟AI去溝通
那AI會去幫你補足
因為它比較廣
它的姿勢層面很多
所以它能補足
你沒有想到的部分
它可能會
以及我們在用Azure的過程中
其實有一些skills
是能幫我們
不停地追問我們的
不停地基於我們提出的問題
去追問我們
讓我們把這個問題想得更清楚的
那同時如果你是這個行業的重疊者
你也需要去補經驗跟判斷
就等於說
我是一個廣告行業跟營銷行業
就有很多點的人
我對於寫一份方案
我是有自己的判斷的
我對於這個行業或者是這個快銷
它應該怎麼樣玩
它是有自己的判斷的
我就要把這個判斷交給AI
讓它去理解這件事情
那基於這個點子之後呢
你就可以讓AI去幫你寫出提示詞
你只需要基於
告訴AI一件事情
叫做基於上面的溝通
幫我把這個提示詞寫出來
然後再基於這個提示詞
去執行一輪
就等於說
開一個新窗口
讓它去跑一輪
最後再去結果的復盤
就等於說
你覺得它跑出來的這個結果
有哪些好的地方
以及哪些不好的地方
去做一個簡單的復盤
那不好的地方
再去告訴它
基於我們以上的溝通
再去幫我改一下這個提示詞
這樣你就能不停的來回
可能來個四五輪
這個提示詞就能非常符合你
入常業務的所需
我這樣跟大家說
但可能腦子裡面有點
這個提示詞應該
好像還
我還是沒有掌握它的這個寫的方式
那我給用那個WorkBuddy
給大家演示一下
大家也可以打開自己WorkBuddy
大家回憶一下
怎麼去操作WorkBuddy這件事情
首先打開WorkBuddy之後
第一件事情是要看甚麼
大家記得嗎
搜封工作空間
選工作空間對吧
因為為了限制這件事情
這個就是我們所說的
叫做AI的素養
你要有自己的這個
這個慢慢的去養成這樣的習慣
第二個就是去選擇
我們所說的模型
你有自己偏好的完全選擇模型
我們剛才那個步驟
其實有一個點叫甚麼
叫做你要先
AI進行的網馬
對吧
你要告訴他今天你要做一件甚麼事情
舉個例子
那假設說我會思考
哎呀
我最近經常要去給老闆去做這種行業的調研
我能不能每一次
老闆讓我去做這個事情的時候
我就能馬上通過一個提示詞
去給他做出系統性的這樣的一個內容呢
就逃避我給你們的提示詞
其實就通過這樣的方式出來的
我會怎麼去做它呢
首先第一點
我這幾天
我我在這裡給大家演示一下
我需要給老闆做一個行業相關的調研
然後我希望從一個行業專家的角度
能夠去把這件事情梳理成一個非常好的報道給他
然後我想你跟我聊一聊這個事情
就是說如果要對一個行業進行谷析
他應該具備哪些維度的這個因素
我現在輸入的東西
我也是用語音的方式給他留
這個也是我們說AI實在一個很重要的事情
你的電腦裡面如果有安裝微信的話
它其實就有這樣的一個功能
這樣的方便
然後你就發現
他就會去思考這個問題
假設今天如果要去給老闆聊這個事情
他應該具備哪些層面
層次一是甚麼
層次二是甚麼
層次三是甚麼
對
然後他現在已經開始有一些
就是就是去做這樣的
可能他會通過一張圖片的方式讓我
呃
去去
因為我們昨天有講過一個事情
叫Wobardi的
他的harness
他做的比較的複雜
因為他裡面放的太過的東西
所以他有的時候會自己去
我甚至都沒讓他說
幫我把這個視覺的感覺給我做出來
他就自己已經開始
再做一張SVG圖給我了
因為為了讓我看起來很舒服
大家兩天還能看到
那同時很多時候
AI在跑的過程中
其實大家不太會去看
AI在做甚麼事情
但我會建議大家去看
就等於說剛才在跑的過程中
其實我會為甚麼會跟大家說
SVG圖這個事情
因為我看到他裡面會在講這個問題
我們有的時候他會藏起來
把這個思考的內容
那你可能就要學會去看這個裡面的內容
因為你才知道
他有哪些步驟是做的對做的差的
好
回到剛才那個任務
我希望說是你
對吧
你我今天要交一份報告給老闆
這個報告如果每一天都要做這個行業分析
其實我的工作是滿意的
那我應該怎麼把它梳理成一個提示詞呢
無非就是我去跟他說
我要做一件甚麼事情
說清楚
問他我應該居的有哪些層面需要看
那這個裡面就會有行業
他會告訴我
所以你需要做行業的基本面
產業鏈的價值分布
競爭格局
需求測的洞察
趨勢於變化
然後他還以一個SVG圖
這種圖叫做SVG圖
他有這樣的方式給我們去呈現
我們看起來是不是會變清晰一點
等於說今天一份報告裡面
就需要有這些內容
那我剛才說到的第二步是甚麼
大家記得嗎
就是假設今天我要去跟AI聊
我第二步其實是
我要把我的行業經驗也告訴他
因為大多數人在做一件事情的時候
你會比AI更清楚
你的老闆平時在跟你聊甚麼事情
對不對
他平時會有他注意要的回度
甚至說關於這個行業
如果你做了地產行業
你可能還要去搜索
關於現在市面上的政策報告
因為政策會非常影響
黃地產市場的一個發展
那如果你做的是快銷
那你可能要去看淘寶等等的一些銷量
這個其實是你基於行業的判斷
你要加進去的問題
那我需要告訴他
我今天想要做的是房地產行業的這樣
我們公司涉及到更多的是房地產行業的
這樣的一個事情
所以是不是要加入更多的這種
政策性的內容在裡面去會更好呢
然後在這個維度的裡面
我覺得這五個維度可能還相對開起來薄弱了一點
是不是還會有更多的東西
你會發現我就是基於我的想法
在跟他溝通這件事情而已
然後他就可能會去思考
那他會基於內居說房地產這個事情
他會跟我聊
我不一定是從房地產的
我只是拿房地產這個案例來跟大家聊
就是你要補足一些經驗性的東西在裡面
那你會發現他現在就在思考
同時他可能會在想說
還是以剛才給你SBG圖的形式去給你做成現
所以會一直去思考這個問題
想要寫非常多
你會看到
我應該怎麼去
他已經想好了
他已經想怎麼做
但他沒有回答我
因為他
我會告訴他
如果我想他這麼久
不用以SBG圖的形式告訴我
就直接一筆文字就行了
我可以打斷他
我可以把這些事情推上去
中間他的運行的過程都其實是可以打斷的
大家要知道
就是你按這個鍵也可以打斷
你按一條新的內容
發上去
他也會打斷
把這個新關掉
我再畫一遍
他就直接
應該來說就不會以SBG圖的形式去發
直接會以一個就是等於說表格或者是簡單的
因為有的時候過程的這些東西會浪費一些托客
或者是時間
好 來了
那他就會說先把先說政策維度
他不是加進去
應該是必須拎到第一位
因為我給他的是房地產行業的這種調研
那我應該把這種政策
然後會有一個政策與監管市場市場基論面
土地市場工區結構
金融與資金面
然後競爭改革企業分化
相對來說就比上一個會更加的詳細一些
會更加的專業一些了
那我們的重點是甚麼呢
我們這節課的重點是教大家怎麼去寫一個這樣的提示詞
到這一步的時候這個提示詞出來沒有
還沒有
這個東西只是一個原則
就是他要寫這個提示詞的原則是甚麼
那回過頭來
那假設說今天如果我想把這種分析
邏輯做成一個提示詞
當我每一次想要分析一個市場的時候
都會有這樣的邏輯
那請你告訴我這樣的提示詞應該是怎麼樣的
直接給我這個提示詞
就我騙了
所以你會發現一件事情
等一下點它出來
它過程肯定還有一些時間
然後呢
我們的核心是甚麼
就是我們跟它聊完了之後
一個好的提示詞怎麼出來的
其實讓電影愛寫出來
並不是我們自己手中寫出來的
我們只需要把前面的東西聊清楚
聊完之後
讓它去寫一個提示詞
等一下它就會給我一個提示詞
那它自己會形成一個文件給我
有的時候我怎麼說呢
就是我不是很喜歡他
莫巴爾尼的一些
就是它的
它過程中會自己加很多細
你就發現我沒有讓它出圖
它就給我出圖了
我沒有讓它寫文件
它就給我寫文件了
因為它裡面設計的東西
就是它的這種工具啊
包括這些
我們所說的這種
這種專家團呀
或者是你本身自帶的這種Skill啊
它會給你加很多的細
但那些說我們用Codex
或者用其他的東西
就沒有那麼的
就是你所有東西
你都給自己去安裝
對有些人來說是好事
對有些人來說
可能就會覺得有點好
好
它現在的這個行業的分析
這個通用分析框架的提示詞就出來了
首先對吧
你要對一個行業進行系統性的副析
那第一前置對齊
那它會說
你需要對甚麼行業
然後怎麼樣去分析
然後第二是行業特徵識別
第三是怎麼樣的一個框架
第一次是Sowall
第一次是乾嘛
那一般我們怎麼去
然後去用這個提示詞就好了
就一般來說
這一步就已經到達
我們剛才說寫提示詞的哪一步
第三步
已經把這個提示詞第一版的做出來了
對不對
那接下來其實最重要的就是要測試
所以說把它全部複製
然後新建一個任務
那這裡也要
想提問一下大家
為甚麼要新建一個任務
為甚麼不在剛才那個裡面去
去直接把
再做一個行業調研
昨天應該有告訴過大家
因為當我們在同一個窗口裡面
去運行這件事情的時候
它會受到上面的東西的混淆
我們上面已經問過了你要調研的是地產行業
那它有可能就會受到那一部分的一些混淆
所以當我們在做一些分開的任務的時候
我們最好就是在旁邊新建一個任務
把這個提示詞混在進去
然後你再告訴他說
最紫定的行業進行谷析
那這個行業我會告訴他
假設是
那是說最紫定的行業
我想想想快銷行業吧
那快銷還是有點辦
我想想想
就是各戶加電
電飯包
更細一點
然後它就會基於我們剛才產出的這份東西
去給我出一份電飯包的市場的行業的調研
所以發現一件事沒有
就是我給你們的那一份HTML的提示詞裡面
它其實好像看起來都是很複雜的東西
但複雜的也是在於我們的行業經驗
但其實生產一個這樣的提示詞
它不是一件難的事情
OK
然後它會因為我們中間有一些問題
所以在這個過程中你可以去選擇
我可以告訴他
這些你可以自己去判斷
不要去問我
有的時候你在網巴里溝通的時候
他下面有坦出一些框
昨天有一些同學其實是沒有去看這些框的
然後就會覺得好像怎麼卡在了
這個地方
因為一般坦出這些框的時候
是它的一個設定
就是它遇到了一些
一定要回答的時候
它會列出選項
你可以選擇它的選項
也可以在下面這個第四的地方
你直接問他
你直接告訴他
你不要去問我
或者你有一些其他的補充
你可以加進去
然後我因為現在在演示
所以我就不需要那個準確
我就只需要告訴他說
你可以自己去判斷
不要去問我
然後他就會基於這個事情
去幫我去搜索各種資料
你看他的過程
他已經去看到了
美地 舒博厄 酒陽 米加 相應
等等那些品牌
對吧
然後就開始去各路調研
調研電漢包市場的基本面
調研 產業鏈 利潤分飛
調研甚麼東西
所以你發現沒有
我的重點在於讓大家看到這份調研出來的報告
而在於我們前面那個環節
到底怎麼一步一步
產出了一個能拿來做深度的行業研究的提示詞
第一步
我先去跟AI做了一件甚麼事情
叫做 Group Home
對吧
我先去探索了一下
我說我要給一個老闆做行業的相關調研
今天我可能調研的是房地產
明天因為我要接觸的客戶是快銷
後天我要接觸的客戶是個這種客戶
那不同的
那我就需要一個行業專家的分析的提示詞
然後我通過一個口語化的語言
我告訴他我要做這樣的一件事情
他就會跟我討論
那在討論的過程中
我就會把我自己想要的事情告訴他
然後他就會說
原來是這樣分析
然後我最後再告訴他一件事情
叫做
那這樣的提示詞
請你給我一份這樣的提示詞
他就會幫你把這件提示詞寫好
然後你拿著這個提示詞
新開一個窗口
我們剛才新開
我們看一下
新開窗口分
是不是就沒選這個
每天還可以擬100的積分
可以去擬一下
在這個裡面
對
然後再拿剛才的這個提示詞
去改裡面的關鍵因素
然後他就可以慢慢的去把這個報告寫出來
他現在已經在開始寫了
我們剛才說是電漢包的這個報告
所以整個的鏈路非常簡單
其實通過了多久
其實也就幾分鐘的時間
就能夠產出一個還不錯可以用的提示詞
等一下我們再過來看這個報告吧
OK大家再回顧一下這條鏈路
大家一定要把這個鏈路深深的刻在這些腦子里
它是我們說
我覺得學AI這件事情
它不單單是在學工具
不是在學用法
以及不是學信息差
它是學一種AI的素顏
它跟我們去學習是一樣的
學以前的語言
數學 英語
為甚麼有人可以說
快速的去寫出一條好的作文
是因為它掌握了跟語言這種文字
去溝通的一種基本的素顏
那AI也是一樣的
它目前作為一個非常蓬勃發展的學科
我們也要掌握與它溝通的一種方式
那其實這個其實就是一個很基礎的一個
我們說在過程中
我們總去跟AI溝通
我們所有的問題都可以通過Agent
去給我們回答
然後只不過在過程中
我們自己要去糾正
以及類似說第二步的地方
我們自己要去告訴AI
哪個地方對哪個地方不對
然後基於這件事情
我今天要闡述一個提示詞
我就去闡運一個提示詞
然後讓AI去執行任務
執行完了之後去復盤
復盤完了之後再回來修改你的提示詞
很多的工作都可以通過這樣的一條電路
來解決掉它
OK
講到這裡
我們再講幾個
讓好用的一個提示詞的小技巧
我相信也有很多人在試面上
或者說之前有聽說過的
第一個東西就是角色的引入
就是你在聽你的
就是內學的時候
你當你不知道怎麼去跟AI溝通的時候
最好的辦法就是甚麼
就是讓他去假設一個專業的人
不能說他沒用
但是確實還是在
就是在我們不知道一件事情的時候
多說這樣一句話
可能能起到一些不錯的反饋
第二就是說
少樣本的提示
甚麼叫少樣本的提示呢
就好比昨天
我們在做那個文案的時候
大家還記得嗎
我們文案的第一個技能是甚麼
是當我們不知道要怎麼去讓他寫這些文案
但是我們有樣本的時候
我們乾嘛
把樣本給到他
所以AI是會學習樣本這件事情的
例如說我在生一張圖的時候
我不知道怎麼去讓圖變得更好看
或者是我想要那個調性的圖
我不知道怎麼形容
那這個時候最好的做法是甚麼
上傳一張相似的圖給他就OK了
所以少樣本提示
或者叫做舉例子
用一個跟圖數大家來點點的話
就是舉例子
它就是一個很好用的做法
那第三就是叫流程鏈
甚麼叫流程鏈
就是我們做一件事情
一定會有第一步做甚麼
第二步做甚麼
第三步做甚麼
第四步做甚麼
當我們給一個任務給到AI的時候
他是很聰明的
他知道怎麼樣去
一步兩步三步往下走
但有可能
他自以為是的那個步驟
實際上是不符合你的業務流程的
舉個例子
例如說寫方案
有的時候寫方案的時候
他是先給你結論
再給你論據
而且論據會藏得比較深
那這個其實是不符合我們去乾嘛
去跟一個人提案時候的狀態
我們不可能先告訴一個老闆說
這個事情你就應該這樣乾
那為甚麼
然後再好像是來補充結論的
我們更應該讓老闆體會到的一件事情
是甚麼
是第一步
因為為甚麼我們看到了甚麼東西
這裡面有甚麼樣的一些趨勢
最後我們覺得這件事情應該怎麼乾
所以這是我們在對一件事情的看的標準
所以流程鏈
就是我們要去告訴AI
你應該第一步做甚麼
第二步做甚麼
第三步做甚麼
尤其對於一些非常高精尖的行業的時候
這個技巧是有一個重要的
當你發現AI一直回答不准你的問題的時候
有可能就這個地方出了問題
那第四就是我們昨天所說的分析後防解
對於一些語言也好
對一些代碼也好
對於一些甚至內容的生產也好
很重要的就是如果說純粹的去給它一個樣板
去做這個事情
它很多時候會盡可能的全操下去
我把裡面的關鍵的文字
我把裡面的關鍵的段落
我把這張圖的這些原數全部放進去
所以我們會有一個介紹,先分析,分析完了得到原則,再去往下錄。這樣的話能極大避免上一個參考物對這件事情的影響。
第四是分塊與組合,有的時候我們要講一個概念叫做我們能看到這樣的一個窗口嗎?大家要知道所有的對話框,它其實都是一個窗口。
那上下的窗口是有限的
大家要理解這個概念
甚麼叫有限呢
就是它能容納的東西是有限的
當東西太多的時候